bella tutti ragazze benvenuti questo
video sono fa dj oggi continuiamo canale
isole show
mi chiedo troppo quando dico all'inizio
lecce ambiente pazienza capitemi ok
finissimi molto d'aiuto c'è un
armadietto si giri veloci e veloce e
veloce
se già fatta già fatta cioè gesù gesù
santa rosa o [ __ ] avuto è fatto rega
non ho idea godo come non so come cazzo
ho fatto non ho idea parte che salì le
scale come mia nonna è dato voglio dire
è fuori quanto sei bello scajola tra
l'altro quindi ti togli per favore dal
caso grazie
togli di pupo toglierti dal ma visto non
raga ma visto ma visto ma visto ma visto
mai visto dai dai giallo mentre sto
cazzo di cosa ma perché non entri sempre
ma vaffan
ho premuto 45 volte lo giuro ma è
rincoglionita non è colpa mia se fai
vedere le tue mani belle a satana che
gambe sexy ragazze fai capire perché
devi rompere i trequarti di minchia ogni
[ __ ] volta scherzavo
scherzavo ora che sto scherzando te ne
vai a fan culo perché mezz'ora che stai
qua se ve la coda mi sono innamorato
proprio non te ne stai andando a minchia
o che mezz'ora e per fare una cagata con
mezz'ora
che palle per oggi e poi guardava janka
si ha funzionato così bravo veloce però
c'è vai vai bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye sea non so dove sono non solo stanno
me ne frega niente
ce la faccio fatta sì sì che botta di
cui 2.000 secondo non sa di sopra veloce
regali e stato orribile
ce l'ho fatta ma è meglio così è perché
poi non è dov'è 18 e 18 grazia di nora
che io non mi giorno non ce la posso più
fa quando finisce sto cazzo di gioco non
si può fare le gare assurdo dove cazzo
sono finito dall'alto di qua non so
neanche cosa ma dov è ma cosa
ma di lancio il tecnico mani sul pettine
son competività ti faccio una piega che
giura non esce di casa vedi che si è
spaventato subito certo e tu che cazzo
vuoi
rendita con lui ecco bravo bravo fargli
il culo due falli culo sto stronzo che
mezz'ora che mi sta rompendo bravo bebè
veglia fuori a di fare il furbo è la
prendi nel culo 33 schifo e non lo
voglio neanche sapere guarda devo
ammettere ripristini interruttore si va
l'importante che non ha tiro a lì in poi
va bene meno uno quartieri deve attivare
giusto per capire la forza tira non
posso perché succeda corrente li
mortacci tua di tua madre guarda che
devi venire giorno io so che deve venire
giù perché stronzo nel cervello come
faccio a tirare sta roba su ciò che hai
tu ma [ __ ] che cosa vuoi scorta è
stato lui è stato lui è stato non mi
rompere i [ __ ]
no no no no no no no no ragazzi non mi
ha visto non mi è ancora vivo ma fatto
ancora la roccia rossastro brucia
t'ammazzo la famiglia pure è viva su
tranquillo è bravo continua a bruciare
ascoltami devo fare una roba veloce
prima che torni seleziona questo
selezionato non lo so
non lo so ma dove muovere il culo prima
che torni stabilizza la corrente gesù
non pensavo di leggere mai questa
scritta ok sondati qua non so neanche
dove si va di qua grado di qua
[ __ ] bella sta cosa
salve sempre cosa dove il bagno perché
fa mi sto cagato addosso e grazie molto
gentile cosa sono sti cosi usava queste
macchine pre masturbare vita verità
comunque prendo se non lo so non stavo
dicendo a te non stavo dicendo a te dove
dovete vendere non c'è non c'è mio dio
che buio si salva ma chi è bella ma ti
sveglia che ci sono le gocciole mio dio
che brutta cosa
cristina corrente nel laboratorio si va
abbiamo capito ma perché mi fanno fare a
me ste cagate basse non ce la posso più
fare giuro che quando torno sulla terra
mi prendono vacanza e [ __ ] tutto
qiesto guerra a salve che jabareen hanno
sempre detto guardami come un importante
essere belli dentro fantastico sei
veramente un frigo ti lascio qua è
comunque complimenti emergency parlarsi
vai vai vai vai vai tira se ci abbia
fatto ciò fatto ciò fatta ho finito ho
vinto o via a me i soldi e le donne c'è
anche una roba ok perfetto perché io
sono il tuo piccolo di tensione del capo
al lavoratore non l'avevo intuito dove
noi dovendo me ne frega niente come ne
sta andando
fai ci turba stronzo è infatti devo
andare lì mi spiace cosa
questo successo i ragazzi da pezzo di
merda no no no non ti ammazzo ti ammazzo
i parenti tutto no dai veramente mi ha
sganciato ci crederò mai che ho fatto
tutto sto bordello e poi mai chiuso
insieme a quello stronzo e ma sganciato
insieme a lui pezzo di sé figlio di
erano anche arrivato dal tutto cos'è
sapevo ragazzi saggi non ce l'ha non ci
posso credere è un pezzo di no non ha
veramente raga io ti ammazzo la famiglia
devo anche raggiungi la chiusa d'aria
allora mi viene il voltastomaco
guardaste cosa se riesco se riesco mai a
tornare dov'ero presso l'isola porta se
ci vai
ciò che posso farcela posso fare mai
apri ragazzi aprista merda cosa devo
fare
aspetta che la chiesa d'aria si presso
l'itis i jazz otto e sei dove sei ma
tanto non può scappare le calcolo
problema non può scappare può scappare
vai vai vai vai vai dentro dentro veloce
si è preso risata non so niente quale
perfetto da ragazzaccia posso fare ciò
posso come faccio a sapere quando si è
personalizzata sto schifo non ce la farò
mai a lo sapete anche voi
se cazzo come lo raggiungo adesso devo
fare una roba troppo alla james bond che
spara tv sta roba sparatevi un cazzo
perché se mi vede sono morto posso
uscire
sì non c'è più non c'è più non c'è più
non c'è chi non so dove non solo è in
fondo vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai su cameron si chiude
come si chiude chiudi è di questo di
sfilare nel ce l'ho fatta
ciò fa grazie a dio cos'è nome tassi ne
sono metterla tutto se non mi chiami si
farà nello spazio abbiamo fatto no
perché
è la madonna che cazzo se è perfetto ci
siamo
non ho già visto st scena in gravi ecco
perfetto aggrappati a qualcosa che sono
volteggi per per l'eternità perfetto ci
siamo ci siamo se brava è un filmato mi
capitava di star giocando io sia troppo
convinto ce l'abbiamo fatta
sono rientrati mio mito è finito dopo
credo è manuel si vai apri apri veloce
apri se sono tornato della navicella di
prima adesso posso andare a prendere
quel figlio di [ __ ] per a calci
tirati ratino sì sì che botta di
l'abbiamo fatta sì ragazzi è stato
atroce atroce dovrebbe essere a posto
aria in perché adesso è rimasto
intrappolato in quella merda e che si è
sganciata quindi dovrei dovrei essere
riuscito
sto tornando al dipartimento discuteremo
lì i tuoi metodi
passo e chiudo posso aggiungere una cosa
io visto che ho lasciato parlare lei
perché ha detto tutte le cose che
pensavo io io c'ho ancora questo ti dico
una roba avresti desiderato che ci fosse
ancora lì
credi in dato non c'è più agli e quindi
posso correre anche bello uccide a pompa
ma allora non torturiamo per bere quello
che bello non nasca giusto per vedere se
funziona poteva avere una morte lenta e
dolorosa ma tipo adesso ti finisco così
eve faccia un primo dato a ecco sono
tornati qui perfetto a ci sono ancora
gli androidi però vabbè ma degli
androidi menef8 c'è chi fosse sta vicino
gli spari in faccia ascoltami di qua il
gol di qualità progetto che se sei
prendi st pesce
ascoltami ce l'abbiamo fatta non so io
non so veramente si prende reali in
prima di uscire la strada vicinale lo
metterà in una stanza chiusi da soli
proprio allora sì ce l'ho fatta di caldo
già fatta mousavi
mai finita vai tranquillo zio mi
dispiace anche a me di averti bruciato
per chi è chi sono sti [ __ ] ragazzi
scolta ascoltatemi in atti non è che
tanto non c'è il miracolo né non passa
attraverso la grata ok non ce la fai la
faccio breve sia da se mia nonna avesse
una pistola avrebbe più mira di te
quindi non ti preoccupare fiordo ragazzi
concluso qui l'episodio prossimi saranno
i finan fosse il prossimo sarà l'ultimo
non lo so comunque siamo alla fine più o
meno spoiler o nulla comunque se il
video è piaciuto ma se questo momento mi
piace anche per gianni facebook e con i
video tratta la restituzione se volessi
di sei principi dal prossimo video belle
ragazze